how good did it feel to get
uh your first solo plaque incredible
i got caught a couple um but
because tribal and gold right tribal
platinum platinum yeah damn that's a
great job
nice job win gold um obviously down bad
is platinum and
costa rica now i think too um that's
huge man
yeah thank you bro you pulled to the
crib you got your your own your own
plaques
yeah i guess that's you yeah nice it's
definitely
it's a blessing bro it's a blessing like
shout out to the whole team
um you know we've been at it for a
minute and it you know i'm somewhere
where
people really believe in that artist's
development you know you gotta that [ __ ]
is a beautiful thing because you know a
lot of labels they're not
you know what it is man they're they're
looking for that well and they're also
looking for something that's already on
fire so they can just put some gasoline
right right right something's already
viral
yeah dreamville i feel like has done a
superb job of
growing each artist you know what i'm
saying whether it's yourself or ari or
god's like
it's like man it's like you see your
guys just come up
yeah everybody's got a touring base you
know everyone's got an album they could
tour
several albums they can tour um you know
like we're kind of like in phase two now
it's like marvel
you know what i mean it's the mcu we're
just going into phase two everybody's
trying to show it's crazy it's a good
that's a good comparison yeah